[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones has just dropped
its first big episode in the season and
this incredible stock showdown is the
best one we've seen well since you're
the big stock showdown this weekend in
Avengers end game this is a nail-biting
90-minute set piece that really feels
like some amazing pay off after a
slightly slower start to the season and
there are some big moments that arguably
stand out as some of the show's best
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the episode as well as what it
could lead to down the line this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the latest release in the season yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way I hope you enjoy
the video now sit back relax and let's
get into my recap of Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 3 okay so just a quick
recap of episode 1 into branded his best
impression of am I'm Jon Snow toll
Daenerys he's anti incest because he
discovered that having sex with his
auntie's incest and that he's the true
heir to the throne and Tommen did one of
the best got milk adverts of all time
episode 3 picks up immediately during
the transition between the calm before
the storm with the soldiers of Westeros
facing down against the White Walkers we
see shaking Samwell Tarly arming himself
with dragonglass and the unsullied and
Dothraki ins already to doth wreck again
sorry that's that's terrible they're
also joined by none other than the red
woman who states she will be dead by the
morning this massively plays into the
end and she helps to arm the soldiers
with fire weapons ready to light up the
landscape it's a battle of Ice and Fire
and whilst it initially seems like the
former may have a chance
the latter pretty quickly beats there
and we realize that this battle isn't
going to be as easy as the last two
episodes it's pretty safe to say that
this is easily one of the most epic Game
of Thrones
scratch that TV episodes ever made and
throughout there's a massive moment of
however the episode two brings in some
pretty heartfelt pieces such as Sansa
and Tyrians exchange in the crypt you
know things are bad when Tyrion says
maybe we should have just stayed married
but it's great that Sansa tells him that
he was the best of them and that's a
compliment because well there's been so
much compared to actually nevermind this
section also gives bran a chance to go
into full Raven mode and using a murder
of crows he begins approaching the night
king and surveying the landscape the
battle rages on with the Hound facing
down a giant and area literally throws
the book at someone when in the library
we also get our first dragon burst
dragon fight and it's absolutely amazing
now for me this is the standout moment
of the episode with John and Danny
pretty much ravaging the night king
unfortunately for them he's harder to
kill than James Bond and we learn that
he's fully fire resistant at this point
the major deaths are coming thick and
fast with linear moment unfortunately
not getting to the point where she can
star on my super sweet 16 and Barrack is
stabbed multiple times and it's unlikely
that he will return with the flame fully
extinguished the night King too has
other plans and he resurrects countless
numbers of the Dead which is when the
forces of Westeros realized that they're
pretty screwed Dany's dragons flee
leaving her to fend for herself John has
to retreat to Bronn Jorah is stabbed and
Brienne is ravaged by whites quicker
than you can say I've just become a
knight it's a pretty devastating moment
that in true Game of Thrones style feels
like a massive gut punch for our heroes
bran returns at this point to his body
but it all feels a little too late with
Theon having to sacrifice himself in
order to buy some more time o Theon at
least you got a chance at redemption but
yeah see you later pal I don't really
like you that much it looks like the
night king finally has his prize and the
two engaging the staring match that
doesn't even feel like bran can win as
the night king approaches him then out
of nowhere comes area stabbing him right
in the gut at the last second and
securing the episode is one of the best
ever
from here the whites all fall to the
ground the battle is over and you can
finally breathe again I've seen some
people say that this was a bit of a
cheap ending but bran did say that he
was going to use himself as bait which
the end he did so area could finally
kill the night king unfortunately that
doesn't mean everything is finished
though there are a lot of casualties
including Jorah who is willing to die in
order to escape the friendzone
this was probably the most devastating
death for me in the episode but at least
you get to see the actor return as
Batman in DC's Titans which are
massively looking forward to malice and
Ray promised that she'd be dead by Dawn
and she doesn't let us down the
character walks out the castle gates and
removes her cape and collar and walks
into the snow aging faster than we did
whilst watching this episode due to this
the character dies because she no longer
has a purpose this entire time she's
been trying to defeat the knight King
and it's likely that she knew all along
the area would be the one to do this
those who remember their first encounter
back in season 3 will recall that the
red woman stated that the two would meet
again but that on the way area would
close many eyes this prophecy is now
fulfilled so Melisandre can rest however
that doesn't mean it's a happy ending
and there are still some large questions
such as why did bran disappear for so
long and why has the show got rid of its
biggest and baddest villain well it
doesn't seem like it actually has it
seems that master manipulator seriously
hoped that this would be the case which
is why she stayed her forces with
Winterfell now in ruins they will be an
easy target for her golden company add
to this the fact that Dany and Jon are
now going to have to deal with who will
get the throne when this is over and it
looks like the Mad Queen prophecy could
still come true personally I think
Cersei is ready to ravage the forces of
Westeros especially with many of their
big numbers now decimated by the white
wall whilst I've seen some angered that
the knight King is no more the show is
actually returning to its roots with the
showdown between the two sides and for
me this makes for a more engaging battle
especially with our heroes being stuck
in such a weak position everything is
building towards who will get the throne
and it doesn't seem so assuring now that
seriously will be the one who is taken
from it especially with the huge losses
that everyone has faced from this bow
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and if you feel like it
lived up to your expectations personally
I was a bit disappointed that there
wasn't a big twist on the night king but
there may be a bigger of your going
forward comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure you
check out my end
explain breakdown of a Bendis and game
which would be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]